we're here at South by Southwest and you
guys are playing Stubbs tonight is it
weird to like to play a smaller venue I
remember you guys might have played
chemos a few years ago San Francisco
there's that tiny little front yeah
we played up in Nashville last summer we
played at we played Bonnaroo and the
night before we played a small local
record store down in the basement you
guys having a good time out here you
know what we're glad to be here very
glad to be here and be a part of the
vibe here man live music is where it's
at for us it's actually it's really fun
cuz it's really relaxed you know right
the set was like two seconds before you
go on play songs you haven't played
playing the different orders you know
start songs stop them start them over
you know get fans to come up and sing I
mean there's always that element to it
we get a chance to do it just often
enough to keep it to keep it fun I've
been asking a lot of beans about Twitter
are you a familiar with this thing yes I
mean do you use it I do not use Twitter
no I don't have the urge to tell people
every time I go to the bathroom yet but
you know it could happen at some point
soon stranger things have happened so at
some point maybe I could sit and go okay
I'm sitting here talking to wire that
it's pretty cool they have their own
camera and so another another technology
thing and feel feel free to tell me to
get lost here but I read that you used
that you downloaded song off a bit
torrent recently yes i did is what was
that wasn't recently it was okay it was
the week before the record came out
already bid a leak and you know it was a
i'll record only lead 10 days before the
release days so as you know that in most
cases that's considered a victory so i
was sitting there 3-4 days and there
were few bottles of wine involved and we
were sitting chatting and was like you
know it my record if anybody can
download this record i guess it's me so
me and my friends found a way to
download Death Magnetic into the
computer there
um there it was and so now I've tried
that yeah it sounded as good as the CD
copy I head out of my car yeah there it
was kind of scary but uh I was I guess I
was uh I was expecting like fireworks to
go off or dancing girls to come out of
like you know somewhere i was just like
there it was and now it says download
complete and I heard the record was like
that's it I did it and so now i can i
can add that to my list of experiences
you go so you guys are you know
obviously like just of legendary status
and there's a lot of bands here at South
by Southwest that are probably wondering
if there ever gets that okay I'll tell
me I can't about it yeah if you're going
to tell an up-and-coming drummer say
like in 2009 what would your advice be
to that guy now in my 40s I'm a little
bit more kind of appreciative of a
bigger picture and back then it was
really all about you know my liver and
my dick basically
you